how's it going everybody it's Warren and
an Avengers in game we got to see Tony
Stark
get married and have a little daughter
Morgan Stark and although this was great
to see on screen many people were
wondering about what happened to
Catherine Langford because she was
supposed to play an older version of
Morgan Stark she was listed on the cast
to be playing the adult version of
Morgan Stark and she did even film a
scene as an adult version of Tony
Stark's daughter Morgan Stark where she
does talk to Tony ultimately this scene
got cut from the movie so I'll break
down what this scene was and why it got
cut in this video but first if you're
new be sure to subscribe to my channel
at the 400,000 subscriber mark I will be
picking three winners and they will each
get to choose one item from the Marvel
Legends series collection and I'll get
more into the giveaway at the end so
recently the Russo brothers went on the
happy sad confused podcast where they
talked about a deleted scene with Tony
Stark and an older version of his
daughter Morgan who was in fact played
by Kathryn Langford here's how the Russo
brothers described the scene they said
that after iron man used the Infinity
stones he would have visited that
mysterious soul realm where Thanos saw
Gamora and got to interact with his
daughter as a grown woman
larysa brother said that during this
scene where Tony Stark gets to talk to
his adult daughter Morgan Morgan says
that she forgives him the wrister
brothers said that this scene was
actually filmed however when they tested
it in front of a screening audience they
said that the audience didn't have a
connection with the older Morgan Stark
and neither did the Russo brothers so
ultimately they decided to cut it from
the movie it makes sense that they would
have at least tried this scene for the
movie when Thanos snapped in Avengers
infinity war he saw Gamora in a soul
realm because that's who he loved the
most and lost and of course Morgan Stark
Tony's daughter is who he would have
loved the most more than anything and if
Thanos saw Gamora after he snapped it
would make sense that Tony would see
Morgan after he snapped the Russo
brothers wanted some closure between
Tony and his daughter Morgan but
ultimately decided that the hologram at
the end was good enough and the audience
that they test screened this for
actually had more of a connection to
Iron Man saying I love you 3,000 more
than they did then say an Iron Man with
his daughter and soul world where she
would say that she forgave him it
certainly would have been a very
interesting scene to see but I
personally loved the fact that the last
thing we hear from Iron Man
is I love you 3000 and I think Tony
would know that Morgan would forgive him
either way because He gave His life to
save the whole entire universe
so I'm fine with it ending the way it
did and as it turns out Catherine
Langford was in fact supposed to be in
the movie she even filmed scenes but
unfortunately they didn't work with the
movie so they got cut so let me know
what you think about this scene would
you have liked to see this play out
after Ironman snap or are you satisfied
with his last words being I love you
3,000 to his daughter be sure to let me
know in the comments down below and as I
mentioned in the very beginning of the
video I'm doing a giveaway at 400,000
subscribers I will be picking not only
one but three winners and each of those
winners will get to choose one item from
the Marvel Legends series collection if
you would like to enter for your chance
to win an item all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
relations to your desperation to save
the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
your number